oh yeah
okay i'm not a bell expert
is
right uh welcome back uh to the workshop
uh uh you know today is uh is all about
lattices uh uh we'll see uh starting
from hux talk
the progress on an open problems on the
complexity of lattice problems uh
followed by a talk of boss club tag on
on the kls
conjecture
and then we'll move on to algorithms in
the afternoon and cryptography so really
it's uh it's going to be a treat
so
thanks very much for node and thanks
everyone for uh for coming so uh today
i'll be talking about the complexity of
lattice problems my my favorite topic
um both giving a bit of a survey or just
discussing the area in general and also
talking about a new hardness proof for
the shortest vector problem
so
i think it's natural that the clicker or
there's like
not good
so
um
so i'll be talking about is uh
complexity of the approximate shortest
vector problem gap svp which is a
computational problem on lattice so as
we all know lattice is the set of all
integer linear combinations of sum and
linearly independent vectors
and usually this parameter n is
what we use when we're thinking about
measuring run times and approximation
factors for for wireless problems
so just as a reminder of what the lp
norm of a vector is i'll actually mostly
just work in the euclidean norm l2 and
drop the subscript p
but occasionally i'll mention other
norms
um so fundamental quantity associated
with lattices is its minimum distance
the length of the shortest non-zero
vector in the lattice
and
the gamma approximate shortest vector
problem
is the problem in which you get a basis
of a lattice and some distance threshold
r is input and the goal is to decide
whether it's a yes instance where lambda
1 is less than r or a no instance where
it's greater than gamma r
so in this picture here this is this is
what you see as input to svp
so here's your basis
and your goal is to decide whether
either all non-zero lattice points uh y
outside this circle so no instance or if
there's some non-zero
uh lattice point inside the blue circle
and so yes
so here if we look at the full lettuce
we see that there are a couple of
non-zero lattice points inside the blue
circle so this is a yes instance of
gamma gap spp
so
again i said this is a this is a talk
about complexity
so just kind of in a panoramic view when
you're thinking about the complexity of
this problem so this sort of slider and
regendra had a similar slide in his talk
where you can think of what happens the
complexity of this problem
as as we vary the
approximation factor which we think of
is depending on
so just at a panoramic level you should
think of
exponential approximation factors being
easy
um
constant approximation factors being
hard
and um
sort of in the middle we have crypto and
what i mean by that is we don't really
know
we don't have like um
can't show as strong of hardness for
these but um assuming that that uh
um svp is hard for some sufficiently
large polynomial approximation factor in
the worst case we get provable hardness
of lattice crypto
so let me zoom in on that and just kind
of look at this in in more detail so
um
starting with the work of ll and and
working forward we actually showed that
i have shown that
um
svp with a slightly sub-exponential
approximation factor is in p
um
so we have that if n approximate svp is
hard in the worst case then sis which is
an average case problem um is provably
hard
and something similar holds for if we
take gamma to be n to the three halves
um for lwe so
if we can prove that um
that gap svp is is hard to within these
factors in the worst case then we get
that lattice crypto
uh is provably secure what's sis again
this is a short integer solutions
problem so
um
yeah it's like something it's actually
so you get
like most like mini crypt primitives
from from sis whereas you get like
uh cryptomania and more from elderly
yeah
um
right
so
um
unfortunately
there are barriers to showing uh
np hardness of these problems as shown
um in in a couple of results around 2000
so
um you have these these results here
where
we actually have reason to believe that
um
that that spp with with polynomial
approximation factors or any
approximation factors greater than this
are not np-hard so
if we showed that n approximate svp is
np hard then the polynomial hierarchy
would collapse which we don't think
that's likely to happen
and then the focus of this talk what i
like to think about a lot is um
sort of the hard regime we do have
provable hardness under standard
complexity assumptions
so this sort of got kicked off in
in the 90s when itai showed that exact
spp
is np hard
and then
if you're willing to make a stronger
hardness assumption of some sort either
some variant of eth
or um
that np is not contained saying
sub-exponential time then you get better
fine-grained hardness or better hardness
of approximation so
we have like exponential hardness for
near
near
exact spp and then for um if you make a
stronger hardness assumption then we get
stronger hardness for near polynomial
approximate
just just to understand
stacking the rectangle from the left
no
co np
so
non-existence of a short vector
yeah so we can't certify that there's no
vector within distance um
say yeah so we can yeah certify either
let's say
yeah so
we can't certify it exactly like exactly
what the distance of uh
of the
the shortest non-zero vector is or
length of the shortest non-zero vectors
we can you can do it for this like
approximate version of the problem so
is it is it just stated that it's in nnp
so it's in np for all approximation
factors so just
you just produce the vector
yeah just the the witness is like
the
for these
for the hardness barrier rectangle is
that this stuff is in
both np and code yeah yeah definitely or
i mean code and co in this case but same
same
so this so then life is not if if
anything
like that is np-complete because
exactly so that's why they're called
hardness barriers so we'd love to show
hardness for
of svp with these approximation factors
but we don't think we can because it
would imply like
complexity what you're saying by that
does that make sense yes now absolutely
yeah
is there any other problem in complexity
with like this many qualitatively
different behaviors
so no but i mean if you want to study
complexity theory just study lattice
problems and believe it or not even
though this has a lot of this has a lot
of stuff on it there's actually even
more to be said about this so you know
i'd love to talk in even more detail
like uh
about this but like
this is even just sort of the the
greatest hits in my opinion for uh
um so quick a question if you
use the other types of
i guess we'll talk about other norms
[Music]
things like lpn will this be covered
also by the top like how the landscape
changes if you
use the coding series
i didn't quite it sounds very close but
i didn't quite catch with you if you
look at the coding theory style of noise
right so lattices you can think of it as
having a linear code and then having
some distribution over noise which is
something specific and then there is the
alternative coding theory so you just
want to you know there are a couple
things going on there but i mean for
noise or thinking you can think of it as
like worst case noise though not average
case
well it's not noise though but like
that's the metric so you can think of it
in terms of the hamming metric so but i
mean really the kind of the key
difference between codes and lattices is
that we're thinking in terms of lp norms
instead of um
instead of hamming norms but codes will
play a key role in in what i say my
question is about this landscape if you
look at codes i mean maybe it's not in
stock but uh no it's a really good
question so um better yeah so codes
actually a lot of things are analogous
between codes and lattices and we
actually do know more i think
maybe i'll let let me just make a remark
and then i'll come back to that and just
just because you brought it up which is
a really good point
um
so right
so this'll keep that in mind
so
but sort of a key a key point here to
observe something that'll be the focus
of this talk
is that all of these hardness results
everything in this left right rectangle
here all of these hardness results are
under randomized complexity assumptions
so
in particular we only know hardness
for exact svp
um
under randomized reductions we don't
even know that that exact svp is np hard
under deterministic
reductions
um
and this is something that came up on
the complexity blog just earlier this
week so uh
you know people are very surprised by
this this is like the hallmark problem
the spp is the hallmark problem and
lattices and yet we can't even show that
exact spp is hard
um so back to the question for codes the
situation is different we know that the
analogous problem to the shortest vector
problem on codes is
under a deterministic reduction that's
actually due to chiang and one
uh and that was actually relatively
recently shown within the last 10 years
i think so
what was the no
just the minimum distance problem which
is the analog of the shortest vector
problem on codes is known to be
np-hard under deterministic reductions
under the standard notion
there is a similar picture that you can
draw for the learning parity with noise
so oh
uh how does it because is there i mean
is there
worse case are there like worst case
average case reductions for lpn yeah
one is there is no worst case traverse
case reduction and up to well i mean
that that's yeah yeah yeah yeah the
worst case strategies reduction so you
have a worst case battery i know that's
not very true but yes
oh that sounds cool i don't care about
it but anyway yeah
yeah no it's interesting so it was
actually as funny as talking to people
like a week ago or so like bangkok about
whether actually we could adapt some of
the techniques say you know from
lattices and port them to codes but it's
not i thought about it a bit it's not i
don't think it's written down it's not
clear that you get anything really
so we're doing
uh to a hard coding problem
uh that sounds like the wrong thing yeah
yeah but it's an easy worst case
recording
problem so
something yeah no that's very nice i
mean
yeah i mean
some of the crypto systems based on lpn
look very similar to ones based on lgp
and like the heart i don't know so what
you need for yeah i don't know anyway i
think they're very nice just like the
the takeaway message here is there a lot
of analogs between codes and lattices
and it's really interesting to think
about
these complexity questions
can you say again why it's the problem
that the reductions are randomized well
i mean it depends on who you ask i mean
for some people well it's not but you
know i mean i mean but that doesn't
prevent you from doing something with
the problem
crypto not really no but i i mean in but
i mean it's like you know why do we care
about deranization in general it's like
we feel like we don't understand a
problem all right got it
given given standard the randomization
assumptions this can be
right yeah yeah sure i mean i was just
wondering if there was some you know
result that that you know you would
would only follow from a deterministic
production but aren't the facts no no i
don't i don't think there's any yeah
i think the point is it's not a problem
it's a disclaimer
yeah well it's i mean it depends
i mean i understand no i i unders i'm
not surprised i was wondering if it
would be you know so there's this
philosophical question how much should
we care about randomness or something
but you know like primes and p is a big
result people really you know in
practice like you just run your bpp
algorithm for for primality testing you
know a few times and you know
everything basically is everything works
but for applications but for the lwe
business at first there was the
disclaimer i'm not sure if it's still
true but at the beginning there was a
disclaimer that it was a quantum
reduction
still yeah i mean there are classical
reductions known now but i guess not
with as strong of parameters right so
problem i don't know but
we're used to this as a type of
disclaimer that's all
you're saying so is there still a range
here where we only have quantum
reductions or
uh i don't know about that's a good
point i don't know about the
approximation factor but there are other
parameters for lwe like the modulus do
you care about and i don't somebody else
knows all the trade-offs between stuff
better than i do but yeah um
all right thanks thanks
same approximation
but there is a qualitative difference
that is where the quantum reduction is
still better it says the quantum
reduction can actually solve with search
problem given the resolver we're not
able to do that with uh with the
classical reduction
and we don't know how to relate search
and decision you know in this in this
approximation
this is a great discussion but i'm also
interested in the rest of it i
appreciate that you know i mean i i kind
of had it in mind like one thing i love
about simon's talks is there's often
great discussion just because there's so
much engagement but yeah let me get a
little further but it's great like
honestly i'd rather just kind of present
the survey stuff and have people talk
about it then you can ask me more
questions offline if you want
um
right so just in summary so here's just
the
uh cutting to the the chase about what
we did
so actually i'll first say what we tried
to do so um chris pikert and i spent a
lot of time trying to prove
deterministic nprness of of svp
so this is actually a problem that i
think danielle machancho is kind of the
world expert on this and has like put a
lot of effort into it
um we started with a lot of what he'd
done and what other people had done what
what uh chang and juan had done for
mvp and um tried to adapt it
so unfortunately we didn't succeed with
this
but um
that's my joke of the i have to explain
it so yeah that's never ever works well
um
but um so what did we do so we gave
what to me yeah i think is the the
simplest randomized np hardness uh
reduction for for svp and kind of the
key new ingredient for this was gadget
lattice is built from reed solomon codes
um we also gave concrete approaches for
for de-randomizing the reduction so like
even though we didn't succeed we have
concrete ideas about how to go about it
that i hope some of you will take a look
at and maybe succeed with
um
and then we also studied applications
and connections of our work with with
other areas particularly to decoding so
um just kind of as as a fun aside so our
it's actually we have good algorithms
for decoding from from our family of
lattices although with slightly
different parameters than we use
in our
in our hardness reduction
and then
our work also gives an approach for
improved list decoding lower bounds to
read solomon codes where here i mean um
list decoding lower bounds in the
standard hammond sets
so
we have yeah we have some cool
applications and connections to other
areas
so whatever else i get to this is this
is sort of the punch line of what we
tried to do the sort of the problem we
were trying to solve and then what we
did do
so
um
we've spent some time now going through
uh what i call the i time chancho
approach for improving np hardness of
svp
is there a question no okay so
um
as with any uh
as with any hardness reduction we need
to pick a starting hard problem so in
this case ours to reduce from so in this
case the starting hard problem is a
variant of the closest vector problem so
to define this i just need one piece of
notation which is just the distance of a
vector t from from a lens
um
right so
gaap cvp
prime
is uh is the variant of of cvp where we
have
stronger promises both in the yes and no
case
so
um in the yes case we're promised not
just that the target is close to the
lattice but that it's close to
a binary combination of basis vectors
and in the no case
we're not just promised that the target
is far from the lattice but
uh we're promised that all
non-zero integer multiples of the target
are far from glass
and um aurora at all proved that this
problem is np hard to approximate within
any constant in the way
this is our starting heart problem
okay so step two is uh kanan's embedding
so
basically sort of what's what's maybe
the first thing you'd think of when
trying to reduce cvp to sp
so um
well
uh it's it's basically this so we
basically just pretend that the target
vector is is just like another basis
vector so just append the target vector
or say minus the target vector
as another
um vector in the basis and then i just
add some orthogonal component but don't
worry about that too much
um just in case it helps anyone this is
basically the same thing you're doing as
like a primal attack on unknown
and then um so if we want to analyze
this reduction so we just i'm i'm
omitting r and say r prime the distance
thresholds but if we just want to think
of this as as a reduction from from cvp
to svp
i'm going to do this by analyzing
analyzing vectors and the lattice
generated by b prime in terms of their
coefficient vectors x prime
um so in the sds case so
assuming that there was in fact a short
vector in the lattice generated by v to
t
um there's there's a short non-zero
vector in the lattice generated by v
prime
so
um this is this is not too hard to see
so um
so we just take the coefficients of the
the close vector uh
there and
we just for our coefficient new
coefficient vector we just take we just
take that x and then just append a one
to it
um
so just qualitatively then
um the distance between
the x and t uh
you're assuming is small and so here we
have a
short non-zero vector in y is generated
by b
um
so for the node and no analysis now we
want to show that for for all non-zero x
prime all coefficient vector non-zero
coefficient vectors x prime b prime x
prime is uh is large
so just based on our our promise from
from gap cvp if y is non-zero this just
kind of follows immediately
um but then there's this problem when y
is zero
so
in other words when
um
b prime x prime is really just
uh bx which is a vector in the origin
so we're just ignoring this last uh
column
and whether this is large or not depends
on the minimum distance of the the
lattice in the input
so this reduction will work what can you
say what's the point of this uh this
last
this term
yeah so i'm like intentionally annoying
it doesn't play a large role in it you
need to set you appropriately but
everything kind of just works so
and i said it to be zero
no but i mean just for actually okay so
actually sometimes you do set it to be
zero like if these are like embedded in
some like higher dimensional space that
actually is how a lot of reductions work
you need i mean you need this last
column to be linearly independent
so that's
yes i mean you need to set you
appropriately but it's not not the
interesting part
so i'm not analyzing that at all it's
true but it's just
you i mean you the reduction works for
that
you don't look convinced but yeah
um
if there's a good reason for it to be
there what why yeah well i mean you need
linear independence that's why yeah so
just think of it that i mean
um
yeah
so
uh yeah so
um in this case like i was saying um
this quantity depends on on the minimum
distance of the original lattice which
you know this reduction would work
basically if and only if the minimum
distance of the original lattice happens
to be large
we don't know in general with it whether
it is so this is kind of the entire
problem with um
uh
um
with with the the approach shown in this
this slide
why we have trouble showing hardness of
of spp
can you um can you tweak the you know
the
the the hardness of the cvp prime uh
right so that's a reduction from some
other ethnic problem like
cover yeah is what they did so that can
you make it can you treat it so that uh
there was something like this actually
past large
uh lambda one um
i'm not sure where you get like direct
uh
i mean
i don't think that just works i need to
think yeah you got like i mean like the
the lattices are like some instruments
or something
but in general sort of the the template
that's uh
you know uh modify the
uh
you know make the gap cvp prime promise
stronger so this becomes actually not a
problem at all yeah
no that's true and i mean um
so yeah it's an interesting approach so
you like sort of just take the take the
issue like downstream or whatever where
or upstream
anyway and yeah try to show like that uh
um
like some
easier version or more even more
restricted version of cvp is in fact
it's an interesting approach i'm not
sure how to do that but yeah
so
um
so
kind of this the standard approach the
item achancho approach is to do
something a bit different
um
which is like we kind of want to
force
this is how you should think about it uh
the minimum distance of
generated by b to be large
and the way we're going to do that is
using geometric objects called locally
dense lattices
so um what's a locally dense lattice so
just intuitively it's a lattice uh and a
and a target pair um such that there are
no short vector non-zero vectors in the
lattice and a whole bunch of closed
vectors whereby close i mean a distance
alpha times lambda one two to the target
um for some constants missing a t
um yeah for some constant uh alpha
between a half and strictly less
so
any such alpha is is good enough in this
this range is good enough um to make
this reduction work
so
um
alpha being smaller is better alpha
can't be less than a half just by the
triangle inequality
two uh lattice vectors which are a
distance 0.6 uh lambda 1 to
your target
each at 0.3
uh distance 0.3 lambda 1 to your target
then uh the distance between them is
um right so
just here's here's like an example just
everything works very nicely just with
the integer lattice if we're thinking
just in two dimensions of course the
challenge
uh you know with with finding these
lattices and see how they come up in the
reduction in a second is in larger
dimensions
um so here
this we look at at um
corners of the unit square so we put a
target in the middle and then we have uh
four vectors at distance
one over square root of two which is
uh
one over square root of two times the
minimum distance
um so
basically what what i thai and machancho
showed and later uh leo lubachewski and
matrancho showed for bdd is that if you
construct one of these these gadgets
um for a given alpha
then you immediately get one over alpha
hardness of of gap svp and
uh
hardness of one over alpha gap svp and
of alpha vdd
okay so like
you you construct one of these these uh
gadgets or a family of these gadgets
with a smaller alpha then you've shown
stronger hardness for lattice problems
so these are also interesting uh
geometric objects in their own right
they're connected to efficient decoding
on lattices and and various other cities
um
right so one key point here is that
um we have a hard time constructing
these these gadgets deterministically so
in fact the key use of randomness in
in hardness reductions is in
constructing these gadget
lattices okay so say we nevertheless
have one of these in hand like how can
we use it to help from with our
reduction from from cvp to
so basically we just
uh tack it on underneath our our
original bases and we do the same thing
with the corresponding targets maybe
with some scaling factor beta whatever
right
um
and uh
kind of the idea now is that
um so again the intuition here is that
the lattice generated by a
has has no short vectors so lambda 1 is
large so this makes lambda 1 of
this whole thing
think of these two this stack is
corresponding to b in the previous slide
you know that uh lambda one of that is
not
okay
um and nevertheless we still have lots
of we have lots of close vectors
so let's just kind of look at this in
the idealized world um in the l infinity
norm
so here we can basically just take take
uh
um our lattice our gadget lattice to be
zn
and we take the target just to be the
all hats vector so i scale that a little
bit when i'm i'm plugging it in here
but um
if you stare at this a bit you'll see
that this this reduction this actually
this reduction here actually just works
this is a full reduction showing
hardness of uh np heart deterministic np
hardness of gap svp in the l infinity
norm
okay
even more uh
approximation
uh yeah well depending on yeah so
depending on the approximation factor
yeah but if we reduce from i don't know
you probably get like
i don't know if yeah two exactly
um
so but um
you should observe that there's
something special going on here so this
reduction worked because there's a
correspondence between um close vectors
in
in our locally dense lattice here and
uh
potential close vectors in the original
ways in terms of the correspondence with
their their coefficient vectors x
okay
um so
kind of the last remaining issue in this
reduction is in general this won't be
true for a locally dense lattice and you
need some way of establishing a
correspondence between close vectors and
the lattice generated by a and lightest
generated by by b
um so
i this is actually
not super interesting for the purposes
of this talk but i just want you to be
aware of it
um
another kind of just one thing that is
worth noting is this is another place
where randomness is typically used
so kind of the main spot is in just
constructing locally dense lattices but
we also needed
using current techniques for
generating
um yeah well it's
so it's
their variants of it the easiest way to
state it which is actually not what we
do exactly but you just map from
um
map
from coefficient vectors which
say take to be binary
of close vectors in
l of a to s
to
onto
all possible coefficient vectors of
close vectors
in this way so that you want like the
entire
uh
hypercube zero one to the end to be
contained in the image
and then you would you stick t like here
so whether
if the linear map is random and uh the
set of uh close vectors
is large enough you expect to hit the
entire yeah you're like kind of hashing
down some
like large set of vectors in some higher
dimension down to like some lower
dimensional space but this you lose a
lot in terms of um
parameters like you know the rank blow
up you need and stuff like that's where
yeah so anyway it's it's an interesting
question whether this can be done better
but
sort of not the step that that's the
focus
um
cool so
right so now we're all experts in
reducing uh cvp to svp
so but there's a question of kind of
like you know what's the story for these
gadgets like this reduction works
assuming that we have these gadgets but
um do they actually exist and if so what
do they look like so i have here like a
summary slide about constructions of
locally dense lattices not just in the
l2 norm but actually in general all
paint
um so the original work showing hardness
of svp constructed these locally dense
lattices from um i guess the schnorr
edelman prime number lattices
and um
so you get get some
nice approximation factors so this is
optimal for what it's worth in in both
l1 and l2 you can't have
smaller alpha
um and uh danielle in his awesome 2001
paper sort of showed that you can
actually de-randomize this reduction
under like a strong number theoretic
conjecture which
seems to be out of reach
um follow-up work constructed locally
dense lattices from from error
correcting codes specifically bch codes
and these these had the sort of nice
property that
um the resulting lattices you get from
from doing this from uh from using these
types of locally dense lattices tensor
nicely
um meaning that
um
sort of as you as you um if you tensor
like a lattice um with itself then
uh the minimum distance squares and so
because of this this let us show or let
danielle and subhash and others show um
uh strong hardness of approximation
results
um more recently some really cool work
um like beautiful work by divesh and
noah um
started looking at
and uh showing fine-grained hardness
results for for svp
and sort of the key here
for fine-grained hardness is having like
exponentially many not just
sub-exponentially many uh close vectors
and so they were able to construct
locally dense lattices
this way um
by uh by using sparsified zn and from uh
so-called exponential kissing number
lasts
classes with exponentially many uh
shorts
um and then we we did a couple of other
works with picard and tang kind of uh
refined this analysis and ported it to
show hardness results for
so the focus of of this talk um is to
talk about another construction based on
codes
which i think is
the simplest all of these may be
um
which is uh
which is to use uh
lattices constructed from read solvent
codes
so simple and hopefully like even more
importantly hopefully be randomized
okay
can you
briefly say what's the source of
randomness in uh
in these uh these other reductions uh
the prime numbers right i mean
it's not about prime numbers it's about
like smooth numbers and intervals so
yeah smooth numbers wind up being what
you need to construct like the target um
so if you have like
you know
uh sufficiently smooth numbers and
sufficiently small intervals are all
sufficiently small intervals then you
can um you can just like iterate through
the interval and just find the point
yeah
so
uh
yeah there are differences in where you
need the randomness in these so
generally um so you know we want to
construct like a lattice target pair for
our locally dense lattice
most of these constructions use the
randomness to sample the
um
the target but actually like there's an
interesting point where with this
sparsified zn actually using the the
randomness we they
have like a fixed target and then
they're actually just taking some random
sub lattice of xen so in that case
you're using the randomness to construct
the the last
target
are these the same assumptions you need
for the analysis of the number fields
and your densities
oh i'm not sure
that they're yeah
no i i i'm sure somebody would know that
better than i yeah i'm not sure
oh okay but that's not it
yeah no that sounds very interesting you
mean for that yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
yeah cool i think it's for the other
constructions specification means to be
forcing a random linear uh constraint on
the on the lattice right yeah exactly
that's what that's so that's that's
what's done here so yeah i mean i didn't
like there's a separate reduction that
subash uses like which uses
specification just as like a primary
thing
um but yeah so i'm hiding that that
detail here but that's another place
where this gets used in his production
so
yeah with his reduction you actually
have two-sided error with the i-time
chancho reduction you only have
one-sided error
so
right
so
let me tell you
about uh our locally dense lattice
construction this sort of last line
um so to do this need a little bit of
notation but hopefully uh not too bad so
just fix q to be a prime and and let k
be um some small polynomial in q like
you can think of k is like q to the 0.01
or something
um
and then i'm going to define uh just the
following matrix this this vanderbond
matrix so you don't have to know what a
parity check matrix is although it'll be
clear from the next definition but just
this is some matrix okay so
i just have
uh
zeroth powers of the numbers from zero
minus one mod q in the first row first
powers in the second row and so on
okay
and um
from from this uh this matrix we can
define a corresponding parity check
lattice so
um it's just a set of all vectors
integer vectors x such that
um
hx mod q is equal to the zero vector
so yeah this should look familiar this
is like the type of lattices or the
construction used for for constructing
lattices and sis just there you're
taking some random matrix a instead of
uh
um
right so
uh for those familiar with it it turns
out that this is uh the parody check
matrix of a particular solomon code so
particular like one with
uh over fq with evaluation set fq and of
dimension q minus k so i'm
the coding theorist might be upset but
i'm using k here to mean co dimension
not to mention
yeah this is so this is the construction
a lattice
we're gonna have to talk
have you
that's i i'd be very curious to hear
about that so not for anything like this
but yeah well i mean yeah but that's
awesome
um yeah it turned out that uh danielle
and nadia had actually thought about
using these these lattices like a while
ago for another application too i guess
not for arms
yeah i use them for packing well very
similar lattices for packing polymers
i mean that might be rough i mean
there's some sort of density thing which
comes up maybe absolutely
yeah so these are they're also dense in
the standard sense anyway so so these
are our these are our locally dense
lattices
right but
um to have a locally dense lattice we
don't just need a lattice we also need
uh a target vector which you are
equivalently a coset of the lattice was
maybe
um
right
so
this will be the most technical slide in
the talk but uh hopefully it's not too
bad so this is basically if you just
take believe me on a couple of things
this will be like the full
randomized construction of locally gas
lattices
um so the key is just to start with is
to analyze the parameters of these
lattices
so
um
the hamming minimum distance of of this
code is is k plus one
okay
but kind of the secret sauce which makes
everything work and like the super cool
thing
is that the l1 minimum distance of these
codes is actually almost twice as large
so that's that's the key that really
makes everything work
so you can define
l1 distance natively on on codes
um it actually has a name it's called
lead distance but that actually doesn't
matter here it's just like it's
equivalent just to um
the l1 so i'm using this the superscript
one to denote the l1 and minimum
distance of the corresponding lattice
okay
and um so
we actually originally adapted a proof
of this for that conway and sloan used
for a close but not identical family of
lattices but then it turned out actually
that
um people had thought of this actually
for this is this exact family of
lattices i guess showing lead distance
lower bounds for these codes
um a while earlier so um i don't want to
talk about this this now i mean it but
it's it's like not a not a hard proof
it's it's nice
uh works by uh fighting newton's
identities
um
so the second thing which is just the
determinant of this code so for integer
lattices um
the determinant is just uh its number of
integer cosets or equivalently um just
the the size of this quotient group
which here is okay
okay
so we have minimum distance at least 2k
and we have determinant q to the k
yeah
yes in general so maybe for yeah so in
jet we have like i mean this was also
already known released
something very close to it was but um
what do you mean by in general i mean
everything is good it's
fixed um no uh
no i mean it depends on like what you
pick q and k to be
so for yeah
there's a choice
yeah and then sometimes like sometimes
it's tight
um
yeah i would actually imply something
too strong i guess if we're in general
uh yeah
exactly i need to say yeah because you
would get like locally dense lattices
that are too good
so yeah but the focus
you know and we can officially construct
like these lattices and stuff you can
take q and k to be whatever you want so
here i'm taking q to be prime not just a
prime powers but um
um
right
this actually has applications
there one thing where you can
reconstruct a multiset from a
that's very much how this this proof
works actually it's something very close
to that yeah
yeah
that's awesome so maybe yeah maybe it's
connected to other stuff
let's suppose that you need efficient
decoding probably right
you know
well yeah there's an interesting point
where ross and siegel actually showed
efficient decoding um in lead distance
or in l1 say from the corresponding
lattices we show like efficient decoding
in l2 that's better than what they is
implied by
a bit of this sign
okay so cool so we understand the two
fundamental uh parameters of our
lattices um
so you just need need one definition
which is just uh the weight age slice of
of the hammock cube so which one is this
okay and so
um
our our goal here like what we're gonna
do let's just think about how we would
construct uh
locally dense lattices here using using
these lattices uh in l1 so we're gonna
do is we're gonna find some some s
such that
the coset
l minus s contains many vectors
in v h
um so for this to work to get alpha
local density we need um
we need to take uh have h
um or current rise in this way we need h
to be less than alpha lambda one so
let's set it equal
to alpha times 2k
and then um
like just sort of we get what we need
just from in an existential sense just
from like a pigeon a whole heart
so in particular
um we get that the
so they're
q to the h many vectors in in this set
in this
and um
they're q to the k cosets and the
lattice
and so some coset has to contain um
at least two to the two alpha minus one
times k um
vectors in bqh which um
if alpha is is greater than than a half
this number is uh is greater than zero
and um just if you remember so this this
q to the epsilon is coming from how i
originally set k which to be uh q to the
epsilon
okay and so that's what we needed right
because this quantity is sub
exponentially large
so the larger ph is actually the better
uh you get more vectors but you show
worse local density
so like there's kind of this trade-off
yeah between the two
so you get more close vectors but like
you're yeah
kind of you get a worse locally than
status in terms of alpha
um right
and it's not hard to get a randomized
version of this you just do kind of like
the most basic thing that you'd imagine
you just sample a random ass from from
bqh i guess the one thing to note is
it's not enough just to sample like
a vector from just like from a uniformly
random coset it has to be one from uh
um but yeah can i recognize if i've
succeeded
i
i don't see how you can but yeah it's a
good question
yeah that's it
yeah there'd be a way
yeah
yeah but don't know it's not obvious so
um yeah i also think yeah it would be
like
there are a few differences from maybe
the normal
um but yeah basically the idea is like
so this is an existential argument it's
very simple so similar ideas have been
used in other proofs to show construct
locally dense lattices
um and it's easy to get a randomized
version of this so kind of the million
dollar question or okay i guess there's
no million dollar bounty on it but just
the key problem here key question is
whether you can um show that something
like like this is true for some
particular s
so fix this
yeah that's true but i assume yeah
you're right so find such an s
efficiently like deterministic time but
like
yeah but maybe there's like a very
simple description of such essays yeah
you're right but technically yeah
generate such s's like in polynomial
time as a function
and that's it that's it
well there's also this like map t i
mentioned earlier but kind of morally
this is the randomness yes
so it's like kind of it seems kind of
ridiculous and maddening this is another
one of these like hay and haystack kind
of things and i say like
conceivably i i believe i don't know
that chris agrees with me on this but
i would bet that maybe any vector s in
here will work
this is strong please falsify that but i
it's not 100 clear but like we ran some
experiments and like
um
these s's are very very uniformly
distributed across uh across cosets
okay so i have five minutes left where
yeah
it's like yeah slightly late that's fine
so okay so
uh
right so just okay how can we do
randomize this so
just based on this is already kind of
the discussion in the previous slide
just summarizing it so we want to find
some like explicit good center s
um
yeah
such that there are many uh many uh
vectors in the equation this coset of
the code or like say around that center
um just like kind of zooming out from
pretty much everything i've said so far
you can just think of like this this
problem as being related to reed solomon
wanting read solomon list decoding lower
bounds but not in the standard sense but
in terms of l1 or lp norms
like think of that as a problem in
isolation it's an interesting question
um
so just one interesting thing that we
showed with a nice assist from swastika
party was um that
sort of if we showed uh this this as is
then it would imply improved
like reed solomon was decoding lower
bounds actually in the standard sets
so you can interpret that in two ways
i'd like to say optimistically that it
gives us like a way of thinking about
improving read solomon list decoding
lower bounds but maybe you can also
think of it as like a barrier
but actually there are kind of way many
ways to kind of get around this it's
just like a strong view randomization
um
so kind of the main approach that we
thought about or we thought about a few
but one is based on discrete fourier
analysis and the bay bound um
something that was used with with great
success um for showing resolument list
decoding lower bounds uh
um for
in the hamming metrics so by
originally my chain one and then uh
viagra swami rudra
and also this is a key ingredient
showing deterministic hardness of the
minimum distance problem
like
clearly this this technique has worked
in the past but somehow it gets stuck
just short of what we needed to do in
our setting i'm happy to talk about that
more but it's kind of again maddening if
the va bound were slightly better then
that would be enough to show like for
what we need but it's not i can explain
yeah but can you experimentally sort of
test if uh if if uh
you know
so see the bong talks about another
roots of uh
folks it's about it's about bounding
exponential sums but actually yeah
um but yeah
so if we have a what yeah actually maybe
i i only have like a minute left but i'd
love to say it's not hard to like
summarize but yeah like maybe just take
that offline so
um
right oh yeah so and like another
another approach we thought of that i
think we had
a few concrete ideas about but also
seemed uh promising was point counting
using gaussian
okay so just to summarize uh in a
nutshell what i talked about so
uh showing deterministic np hardness of
svp is is a beautiful question and
unfortunately still open but i hope that
somebody in this room will will solve
this
um
and uh again i really you know i think
that our i like my bias but i i like our
reduction i really think it's it's the
simplest one there is and i think
they're like interesting concrete
directions to
pursue
uh for de-randomizing it so we thought
about them a lot but i think there is a
lot more to think about there
and so um
just kind of jumping back to svp more
generally i just want to state um
four things that i think are very
interesting problems in the complexity
of scp so the first is what i talked
about to prove deterministic np hardness
of svp
um the second
could summarize is reducing number
theoretic crypto to lwe so
reduce
efficiently reduce factoring and
discrete logs say to end of the 10
approximate svp
third is to show
some like
fine grain hardness of svp but like
strong fine-grained hardness so like say
two to the n over five hardness of exact
sdp
under a standard complexity assumption
so like something maybe something like
that
and uh the last which seems very
challenging is basically just to prove
uh hardness of lwe or something or
under a standard complexity assumption
so like as i said before we don't expect
to be able to show np hardness of this
problem but kind of there's this
beautiful area of fine grained
complexity and and other areas where we
have a whole bunch of interesting other
assumptions which might be appropriate
for showing so
okay and then
i'll just leave you with with some
parting words of wisdom for free
yeah you mentioned the
results of sloan and that's and then
this other seagull and braun
uh yeah for the
lower bound on the laid distance um
i was having trouble finding the sloane
paper so i'll have to it's in the book
conway swan like in the just like in
splat sphere packing class so they
actually they have it for like in
another context also it's for craig
lattices not for
construction
they're closely related okay we
originally adapted the proof we found
there and then
look look for craig lattices and
congress
and then the follow so you know
they're like sorry are there like upper
bounds on
this strike in the late mess right
uh
on the minimum distance you mean or yeah
yeah so i mean in general the 2k is
tight that was i think nowhere somebody
has that yeah
we have an example in our paper uh
that's the case
yeah so you know
so here's the possibly crazy approach uh
to proving to to randomize following
what duval
was asking right so assume that
cvp prime is hard
use that to construct a pseudorandom
generator
like one that is one that actually
produces uh this sort of gadget vladis
right so now there are two possibilities
either this this this this is random
enough
to the reduction in which case it will
actually work
or it's not in this case you break gap c
would be prime so in either case you
break break
uh wait but
you're
you're thinking of some variant gap cvp
prime instances again
just just
start from a hard problem right yeah
okay yeah
okay
we know hardness to randomness sort of
uh you know
you have very broadly right uh
yeah
yeah
yeah saying a particular kind of
surrounding geometer one that will pull
the particular
no it's true so either it does fool the
reduction right or it doesn't
uh in which case you you break you have
to be fine yeah no it's a nice that's an
interesting idea so yeah okay no it's
yeah
it won't be pretty but uh i don't know
it's it's it seems seems right
to get like a generic
no you don't want one like a very
very simple tasks yeah right uh
yeah also did you guys look into there
is this paper of singapore
randomized algorithm
we didn't know i mean no is the short
answer i mean we didn't look at
like go deep into the kind of generic
de-randomization literature like we were
trying to use techniques like uh you
know
and stuff that had worked specifically
in this context before but i mean i
think just both of your yeah vanilla
video balls questions
yeah
well this is a comment and maybe some
some brag but also sort of a question
because it might be relevant or
what i was doing was was
exploring
uh
how close you can get to the volume or
hamming bound
in this context
context of the l1 norm or hamming for b
metric for
packing from z to the end
and
i took the
an odd version of the kreg lattice so i
actually took the prime to b
you're prime q to be
twice the dimension plus one
so that so that the residues only went
from one to q to the minus one over
u over two
okay
and so then uh but then otherwise it was
the same kernel that you set up and what
i showed is that for any minimum
distance
as the dimension goes to infinity
the packing density doesn't go to zero
so that the volume bound is
just tight to within a constant factor
and that's rail one you said yeah
interesting
so this is a yeah it's an analogous
property
yeah
there's no property
yeah
the the volume bound height to within a
constant factor as the size of the ech
code
yeah for any fixed minimum distance now
the
the amount
the constant is dependent on the minimum
distance so
it's further away as from the volume
that's
super interesting i mean it's you know
it seems i'm bringing it up because it
seems some i don't understand this
material very well but it seems like it
could be
related to these locally dense
properties that that actually
yeah so there's an interesting question
about the connection between like
density and local density also so for um
like in
lattice world i guess like a lattice is
dense if it's nearly tight with
minkowski's bound and depending on how
you parameterize um
vaporize these lattices you do get
um
you do get like lattices that are uh
essentially tight like say i mean it
depends on how you parameterize it but
in some regimes tied up to a constant
i might add like density does not
well it seems i mean at least for your
randomly chosen thing i mean i mean
like you idealize it as a perfect
packing you know an actual tiling where
yeah
ball
radius k
and then it just somehow does seem
related
yeah no i mean it's it's a very yeah
i didn't see your yeah unfortunately
didn't see your paper
you wouldn't i mean
the papers are kind of
falling a lot of things you wouldn't but
yeah that'd be great
okay sounds good
[Applause]
what's